how many shows do you think you've
pitched
since you started
I mean I've had
two shows that I produced and starred in
and I had another six Pilots or variants
of series that I got on air six that you
were part of either wrote produced or
acted in yeah no it's eight but six I
wasn't on camera so let's say that's
ridiculous out of how many well like
some went 30 apps some went six some
went pilot but what about the ones that
didn't get made out of shows I've
probably pitched
I would say it's more it's not as many
as you think but it's one show a lot of
pitches I pitched one show 23 networks
hey there folks it's Michael Rosenbaum
and boy have I got a huge announcement
for you this has been a long time coming
and it's finally here
I'm doing a live podcast my podcast
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum is
going live yeah for the first time ever
on Wednesday October 11th at the iconic
Regent in Los Angeles and guess what I'm
not going to be alone
um we're bringing a guest you might
remember he's been on the podcast he's a
friend of the show the one the only
Zachary Levi we're gonna catch up on
life and mental health and we're gonna
have a really good time with all of you
I think you know that we're going to
make it a lot of fun we're planning a q
a maybe some fun games other exclusive
stuff you're only going to get by seeing
it live we're even hosting a VIP meet
and greet for a small number of people
before the show begins grab your tickets
mark your calendars and get ready for
the night of laughs insights and
Unforgettable moments tickets are
limited so don't miss your chance to
join us on October 11th at the Regent in
Los Angeles get your tickets now at
insideofulive.com this is going to be an
epic night so if you're in the area come
out and I'll see you there
and everyone laughed and they never
bought it so at least a hundred
different ideas I've taken around
multiple times and you've had eight that
yeah about eight percent that's that's
not terrible that's really good yeah but
I never got past
to 66 like I had one more season for
syndication do you know what I'm saying
like my show would have been one more
season syndication and then boom Jamie
Jamie Kennedy experiment experiment yeah
which why was it like you know I know it
was canceled after two seasons but it
was the highest rated show it was like
it was why why did they just let it go
so quickly
I'll tell you exactly why so we got the
show we were making the show the show is
like when things in Hollywood are made
good I believe they're made kind of on a
fluke right so the show started because
Jordan who is a great guy gave you know
us very big breaks Jordan 11.
he was running the network and he was
he was cool he was like us he was like a
young guy right you're right he loved to
go to Morton's he loved to drink wine
he's always happy he knew he knew pop
music he was fun he was in and Suzanne
Daniels also young and exciting and the
WB was this new place where I've never
seen
programming for younger people let alone
a whole network dedicated to it right
that was like young y-a yeah and it was
Sarah Michelle was like you know the
poster child yeah yeah so he was a big
fan of Comedy
and he says I want you to do a tape for
the sales people and he says I want you
to go and do a prank on them and you're
going to play their a big guy you're
going to play the Network's nephew who's
got ideas for products and they're going
to film it and they filmed it
and I was in there pitching like
Coca-Cola salesperson I'm like let's go
back to the original formula bro he's
like what do you mean I'm like a little
cocaina you know like people need more
energy Red Bull's killing you let's
figure this out Colombian Coke like the
guy was like so everything was a new
product and I would just give it in the
Swiffer like all these different
products great reactions huge thing
plated at the upfronts as a as a break
in between show and show says so they're
showing you Smallville or you know
seventh heaven they're showing a break
and this show was shown as the break it
killed it was the perfect thing because
it was on the advertisement so it wasn't
sold yet no this was just uh it was
literally it was like a a successful
interstitial to keep people happy as
they're showing new shows and keeping
the advertisers happy were you surprised
that it went this well I knew it went
well and he I knew that if it did
something he's a creative guy so it
would have been an idea it was perfect
because we played it at the place that
where people were buying the stuff and
it was their friends who were getting
pranked it was like you know 2 000
people in New York
killed and he's like we got to do a show
like that night he's like we got to do a
show okay so it takes off and boom
numbers are great and all that so yeah
then we do it takes off numbers are
great
and then second year uh we're traveling
more orders the whole season the third
year get the whole season order a ton of
cities
corporate sales
what happened was there was a corporate
restructuring and that had of I want to
say Warner Brothers
TV changed
and so Jordan left a new guy came in and
asked her fat was trimmed you cap you
were one of the few that got to stay and
we got we got axed a lot of us got asked
how how hard is it for you how hard was
it for you then
when something gets canceled compared to
how you react now
uh I'll tell you a couple things what's
crazy is is that Comedy Central was
dying for the show this is gonna be good
this is a good moment for you like it
hurts
two places one ABC family and Comedy
Central Comedy Central was begging for
the show they said we're going to pair
it with Chappelle
this studio or the somebody in ownership
goes We're Not Gonna sell it to you
unless you take all episodes produced
and they didn't they did because they
were planning on doing more seasons and
they said no we're just gonna buy what
we want now and he goes you know you
have to take all future episodes and
they said
no
that deal was killed
and they sold the ABC Family
ABC Family ran it for six weeks and then
said we're changing our mandates
so it was gone in six weeks Comedy
Central meanwhile Chappelle blows up
because of reruns because of the DVDs
would have got that second window I
believe
so when it was canceled though I was
doing a lot I was doing movies I was
doing stuff so I was like okay it was a
good run an amazing springboard I'll
look at my next thing
but
when it went down I had a few other
things go down and then I was definitely
bummed would I be as bummed as I would I
would not be nearly as bummed now but
then I was pretty damn bombed